you know we're talking about veritas and
the victory and i want to keep
raining down sunshine on people because
please it started really dark i mean the
julian honestly
it's freaky feels good ladies and
gentlemen we've got a secret weapon oh
you ready for this
ultimate secret weapon i'm ready it is
the return of magareli's i'm kidding
but donald trump is planning uh he may
hold maga rallies
beginning in may according to a report
he may the trump brothers are going to
come back
and you know i jokingly say it's a
secret weapon but it is going to start
kicking things back up getting people
back in
in focus maybe not uh you know there's
there are some bad people i guess but
the general idea is getting people to
center around something
probably something better than i don't
know just
pessimism and black pills yeah i don't
man i i hate trash and trump because
he's not a horrible human but i just
i don't like that he's the guy i mean
yep that's right he's got money he's got
many fatal flaws
many one of them is this desperate need
to be liked
yeah has to be liked and as darren b
very astutely pointed out on our last
friday sessions check it out
youtube.com forward slash jack murphy
live
he was an insider trump insider i also
interviewed amanda milius at the same
time and also a trump insider and they
both were very honest
and very open and candid about the flaws
of the trump administration
from the perspective of true maga
believers
who were appointed by the president
right
so this is an honest assessment as
you're gonna get and one of the things
that they drilled down on was the fact
that trump needed to be liked and what
that translated into was him saying
things like
oh there's no there's everybody loves us
on campus oh there's no dis there's no
there's no conflicts in the street oh
everybody everything's great
everything's great about this everybody
loves stocks
right but at the same time there was
actually violence you couldn't wear a
maga hat on campus there was actually
violence at the rallies there was
actually people
you know attacking other people for
supporting trump and so his
desire to reframe everything as no they
love us
actually ran cover for the negative
things that were happening
uh on the ground and so when
he makes noises about 2024 or starting
the rallies again
i don't get excited i truly am not
excited
about that i i wish i were i wish there
was a 3.0 person who was like
ready to beat the trump that we really
need now
uh but uh that person hasn't seemed to
materialize
just yet and trump desantis you know i i
just don't i've watched him in florida
i don't know too terribly much about him
the people of florida may not vote for
him as president because they want him
to stay
as governor you never know crazy things
have happened trump had that star power
he was a famous famous business mogul
like who it'd be like mark cuban elon
musk like who's a
zuckerberg you know some crazy not him
obviously
trump before he was president more
famous than all three of those guys are
now yeah
i wish so famous i wish zuckerberg would
have run on the democratic ticket
that'd be cool in 2020 you know why
because anyway
well actually i don't know if we would
have won but it would have been
hilarious to see him trying to
it would have been the worst possible
thing for the people of this planet
but it would have been hilarious to have
like you know zuckerberg is like a
combination of data from star trek and
the joker he looks like data
he's right it really looks like they so
it does oh so like uh like lore
basically well no no no no
uh in star trek laura is data's brother
he's another but he's like
megalomaniacal yeah that that that
doesn't really work no no like
they did a good twin bad twin shtick
with data in his android brother well so
the original
uh i think lore was first synthetic
humanoid
was with emotions and he became
sociopathic
so then data was created without
emotions and had to like learn or
whatever but
no no it's not a fair comparison it
would actually be like you know data
wasn't
was a was a good person you know
struggling and trying to learn how to
become human
you take that element of the very
analytical data driven
and combine it with the joker and you
get mark zuckerberg
it would have been a hilarious
presidency i've been awesome but but
he's more powerful now
right so he didn't want to do it yeah
and that's a sad statement when we find
out that the corporations are more
powerful than the presidency of the
united
states that's a problem you know
libertarians
fix that let me tell you i've been
having i've been laughing all day
so uh you may you might not know this
but
i actually got more heavily involved
well let me let me
i got heavily involved in politics
through just general activism i was
younger in music
and i worked for non-profits but there
was a period where i started hanging out
hacker spaces in like 2010
2011. so i became friends with a lot of
very prominent hackers
in these in these spaces hacker spaces
and at the time
anonymous was really big the hacker you
know collective online
and a couple other groups like
telecomics some of these individuals
stayed true to their data love and
libertarian principles of rejecting
authoritarianism
but something really interesting
happened there's a hacker convention
called defcon
which is a very prominent sort of the
biggest hacker convention they also have
black cat which is very corporate
and we were watching like my friends
some of these very prominent well-known
famous hackers
the woke infestation and activists
started coming to the hacker conferences
people who are not hackers at all
who didn't understand the culture didn't
understand the symbols didn't understand
what it like literally anything about
agriculture but they liked the
activism that they saw from hackers so
they started coming in
some of these people at the time were
very very
anti-intelligence agency i mean there
were people screaming and ranting about
spying and all that stuff and something
really interesting happened i think it
was
a few years ago a four one guy
was speaking at def con and made a
statement where he was supporting
law enforcement and the audience started
clapping and cheering and he was like
wow
never thought i would give a speech at
def con and have people cheer for the
federal government
and they were cheering because he was
speaking about russian interference and
things like that
my favorite thing all day i've been just
laughing slapping my knee
are some of these hacktivist antifa
people that i know
cheering on the fbi right now and so
i've been commenting on their pages i'm
like i am so glad to see you've been
de-radicalized and you're on board with
the federal government
you know i was really worried because
you were very anti you were very
extremist under government when i knew
you
to see you now fully on board with
authority and the liberal you know the
liberal uh
you know liberals running the government
it's it's it's a good thing
and all of a sudden their brains like oh
you broke them did it work well they're
rebooting we'll find out
right right now they'll come back with
something else it won't rain
there's no way to shake people free even
with logic in their own behavior held up
to them with a mirror one inch from
their face
it's like one out of ten it takes trauma
it takes serious trauma where you're
where you finally have to admit
that your mental model of the world is
not leading you into productive outcomes
i got it i got it i got an idea
uh oh here's what you got to do all
right acid hail no
no go to your go to your friends and
family right
the ones that you know are the ones that
are still talking to me yeah the ones
that like
i'd be like do you guys want to go see
this this this band play
you want to go see a band and then when
they're like oh sure like
we're gonna we're gonna go out and see
this big show it's gonna be fantastic
it's gonna be this famous uh you know
saxophonist or something
and then you bring him to a mogarelli
and then you pull up in the parking lot
you walk up they're like why is it
wearing monkey hats like oh i don't know
and then you get them in and then
they're standing there like what's going
on and that's when trump comes out
and then they're going to be like what's
that but then they're going to see it's
a bunch of regular people and everyone's
going to be smiling there's going to be
babies and then people can be shaking
hands and donald trump's going to be you
know
i'm kidding by the way don't really do
that oh i was like i was like signing
people up in my head
visioning in my mind what was going to
happen when he started when he starts
going
lock her up lock her up well i don't
think i'll do that now
right now especially because giuliani's
gonna be in jail we just we just watched
earlier the curb your enthusiasm where
he gets the idea where the manga hat
yeah so no one will talk so
good because he has he has to have a
meeting larry david has
have a meeting with a guy doesn't like
yeah so he gets the idea to wear a maga
hat and the guy is like sitting in the
restaurant and he's like uh i i gotta go
and i don't want to be here so then my
favorite bit is when he's driving
and he cuts off the biker and the biker
is like yelling at him like ah
so he pulls over and then he puts the
hat on and then the biker goes just be
more careful next time and then she
leaves
that was a great show that was good it's
a good show he he is uh
id unchecked right like just behaving
with no regard for anyone else about
anything
his fields offs are fallow as f
indeed yes that's great do you think
i mean this is kind of an obvious thing
when we talk about the giuliani thing we
didn't even mention the uh
hunter biden email laptop right giuliani
basically spearheaded
and popularized as best as he could
makes me think that it's a political
but i still don't know any of the
evidence maybe he did something wrong
dude we sit here and
we look at these facts and we're like we
are so right we're so right about
everything
the insurgents bullcrap the retribution
bullcrap
the the the like stepping on the
constitution
all these things all the election stuff
we're like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
we are
we are so comfortable in our position
what do you mean i just i mean i'm open
to challenges and critique but like
i'm pretty sure that the way we see the
world is accurate
but there's a there's another group of
four
sitting around right now somewhere doing
a podcast right now looking at the same
fact pattern and saying a narrative
completely opposite 180 of what we're
saying and they feel
as secure as we do they're right sure
this is the problem there's a podcast
it's called like things you should know
or something have you ever heard of it
nope have you ever heard of that
no stuff you should know young
genociders or something no no
no no it's just like some dudes sitting
around but i listened to one of these
episodes and
again i could be wrong by the name of
the podcast but they were talking about
like climate change and then one of the
guys is like
dude like i mean fossil fuels are gonna
run out anyway we need to start doing
research and the other guy goes
like yeah dude like there's never gonna
be dinosaurs you know what i mean
and the guy's like right like fossil
fuels are dinosaurs and we're not gonna
have more dinosaurs and then the guy's
like
could you imagine if they like made a
jurassic park thing to like make more
dinosaurs so we can get more oil
and i was like what the these what is
this
it's a top podcast first of all we
already synthesized petroleum with algae
it's not dinosaurs wow lots of ways blue
crude
there's lots of ways to make oil
nowadays yeah yeah pressure
complete plastic with no oxygen well
really convert it back and convert it
back
so i i was like these these people
they're people who genuinely think
petroleum is dinosaurs oh my it's like
dude it's it's not i think i think it's
mostly algae anyway it's just
it's just organic matter decomposed for
the most part i believe but regardless
it's like i just i was reading an
article like the week before about a
breakthrough in synthesized petroleum
it's not really energy efficient to do
it's energy efficient for us to take it
out of the ground because it's already
been created
and maybe there's you know other things
we can do but there are people
when they sit around in their pockets
they talk about stuff yeah they're dumb
they're dumb they really are dumb so no
there is no one else that's looking at
the facts like we are we should be
as deservedly assured in our positions
as we are in ours
it's it's it's listen when i when i talk
to are we the dummies
no no no i'll tell you this
we may not be correct very good we may
not be correct
it may be that we only see the surface
layer of the giuliani fbi thing and
below the surface it could be man it
could be nuts
for all we know aliens are involved i
have no idea top secret
i mean true it was my first reaction to
be like look
the fbi department of justice a judge
signed off on a warrant
like we have a system in place to make
sure that nothing frivolous like this
happens so
my first instinct is to be like man that
giuliani done
effed up somehow but what if
but aliens yes are holding our
government hostage
true and told the judge he had to do it
yeah vampire aliens
vampire aliens yeah but who can actually
see themselves in mirrors
yes yeah and then teleport right yeah
the point i'm making is
i'm a gorilla in in yeah i am
the reality though is that there's
confidential stuff we don't know about
definitely i'm not saying it's justified
i'm not saying i know what the story is
it could very well be
that like uh mission impossible like
team
stole the vial of you know the jet fro
saw the vial of fuel from the genesis
device and rudy giuliani
has a laptop with the file and it
doesn't realize it i don't know i'm just
saying there's a lot of stuff we don't
know
so we're sitting here as informed as
informed as we can be
we may be wrong about all of this stuff
for all we know
russia's secretly at war with you know
some country and there's just a whole
bunch of stuff we don't know what's
going on
but i will tell you when i listen to
these other shows
i can immediately say they never read
that story they never read that story
they don't know about this conflict they
don't know about that conflict
you look at the stuff with giuliani
right now i did a segment on it uh for
my main channel
do you know what the giuliani stuff is
really about is it it said that he was
advocating on behalf of
ukraine syria well it's about the
pipeline
what's going on with stream two so so
let me let me tell you my thoughts
do you think that joe biden got a
prosecutor fired to cover up for his son
who was being
who's facing potential corruption
investigation sounds plausible to me
what what i think the issue for a lot of
people is
if that's all you know it sounds like
that's what joe biden did
however i think there's a more obvious
reason hunter biden was on the board of
burisma
gazprom has controls a large portion of
the natural gas coming into
the european union that's through
ukraine and is controlled by russia
so us and western interests need energy
companies
loyal to the west not russia and so
there's been a series of conflicts
one the euromaidan protest the
separatist movement nato and its allies
the west the united states
want control of nato want control of
ukraine
so that they can control the flow of
natural gas into europe through these
pipelines
russia wants ukraine in the trade
federation separatist fights break out
so the u.s goes to syria and says maybe
we can off
offset this monopoly by building the
qatar turkey pipeline
my personal opinion and i'm lacking a
ton of information
is that joe biden's intervention
in the investigation into barisma of
which there was an investigation
according to matt taibi
was to protect western interests not
because the prosecutor was corrupt
the prosecutor likely was loyal to the
country of ukraine not the united states
and near european union
and not necessarily to russia but an
investigation into prison was bad for
the u.s
so biden intervenes and his son was
there incidentally because
the u.s positioned key figures who are
loyal to this country
what's a guarantee you want someone out
of the country you put a c a former cia
director which they did
and the son of the sitting vice
president now you know this company will
always have your back
and you don't got to worry about an
assad saying nam with russia that makes
more sense
rudy giuliani starts digging up
information into what's going on
and maybe could it because i'm saying
there's so much i don't know
underneath the surface but maybe what
was happening was that individuals in
ukraine
were giving into information to giuliani
and
trump allies that would have shown the
us was meddling in the national affairs
of ukraine
for us and european interests not
ukrainian interests
and if ukrainian people find out about
that they will reject nato because they
don't want to live under a boot ever
again yes
my opinion i don't know if it's true or
not because i don't have access to
confidential information
there's probably a bunch of other
stories i haven't seen but it is a long
and complicated story
no that seems to make sense also tim by
the way
you what an encyclopedia of information
do you read and retain more than most
people i've ever met in my whole life
very impressive
so when we talk about these lefty
podcast people who are like
dude joking was not
was not a good he was corrupt and then
it's like did you read matt taibi's
piece on this
no why didn't you i don't know it
existed all right well that's a good
excuse i suppose i can't blame someone
for not
knowing because i don't know things that
you know there are things exist i don't
know about
but matt man did he did he nailed this
when he did his investigation and he
said
there was like a dozen active
investigations against barisma and this
corrupt this corrupt guy who flees the
country
and so to say that there was no
investigation
you know you know i'm gonna say this
guys intelligence
bros who are watching this show i'm
sorry i just think you're bad at what
you do
now uh hold on hold on you're probably
really good at what you do by your
standards and by relative standards
but i just think i could do a better job
like if you wanted to actually convince
people of us interests and like why
it's important to have more energy
flowing into the european union
particularly because
the european union one of its goals is
to compete against china
because they needed european countries
unified i mean maybe that's the message
you should have rolled with
instead of it's all a lie trust the
mainstream media and then when people
catch them in lies what do you do
man these people have no it's like being
honest
is actually the best way to go about it
insulting the intelligence of people
with garbage stories and banning
someone's name from youtube
doesn't solve the problem it makes it
worse i kind of feel like
the intelligence agencies were handed
off to a bunch of young kids
the next generation of deep state who
are like i don't know how to run this
thing
and now it's all falling apart that
happens every generation i think
though i've seen it happen especially in
wall street and finance where like the
younger guys
they figure out new investment
strategies new asset classes and they
go all crazy and the risk management
folks and the senior partners have no
idea what they're doing
that's where you can make some real
money and in the intelligence
industry you know i mean look it's i
think it's pretty much like that
in all in all industries but what i'm
struck by here especially
is how much of the
of the surface water of our foreign
policy and economic policy and politics
is all subterfuge the real things are
happening below their title forces
and in this case it's about energy right
and the whole syrian no-fly zone from
2016
clinton proposition uh to the you know
people being mad at trump for wanting to
calm down tensions in syria
and calm down tensions with all this is
based around pipelines it's all based
around
energy and it's a much deeper structural
thing
that has nothing to do with some of the
surface stuff that we get distracted by
and that's how i know we're on the right
side
is because the the left they want a
circumstance in which the people of the
european union have less access to
energy
and that the people of ukraine don't
have sovereign decision over there
right over their country and and and our
side wants
more energy into the european union and
for the ukrainian people to decide their
sovereignty well no no
i think the the establishment wants more
energy into the european union
but they don't care about you a specific
kind well no they
they want i don't know
again there's more details that we need
and i am certainly not an expert on this
subject
let me give you a hypothetical all right
donald trump i'm much better with those
donald trump comes into office and
immediately michael flynn says china's a
bigger threat
intelligence agencies then say we know
china is a bigger threat but don't say
it out loud because we are actively
building up our resistance the european
union was
formed partly to to create a competitive
economic block that can compete against
the growth of china
and we need and and russia's in the way
russia is actually in many ways hates
china but also works with them
we need to get more energy into the
european union trump comes trump comes
in and says i don't care about this
ukraine stuff
i don't care about the serious stuff
america first all the way
and then you have these intelligence
agencies saying the first thing we have
to do
to grow and be competitive is have more
energy into europe to grow european
influence not chinese or russian
influence i know russia is partly in
in europe then you get trump pulling out
of syria
which means over the past four years
trump was stopping
the establishment plan to get more more
energy into the european union
and to weaken russia which in turn would
weaken china
trump went straight for the throat with
china and then got all these peace
agreements
which made it even harder for the us to
operate in the middle east to maintain
control over the region
the us isn't there because there's you
know terror or whatever
and the fact this con conflict between
these countries is good for the us
because we'd be like oh no we have to be
there
we have to send all these bombs to to
these different countries egypt needs
our military aid
trump bringing about peace well now the
us is like
what's our justification to the american
people and european people in australia
or whatever our allies
what's the justification for being in a
country when trump brings peace
justification now is we need to bring
transgenderism to the women of
afghanistan pakistan
pakistan pakistan it was like what was
it 10 million dollars so listen i say
it's hypothetical
and the reason why after knowing like
after re researching the things that
i've researched and seeing this
you know talking to the journalists
reading the stories the reason why i
don't trust the establishment
is because they lie all the time and
don't deserve
trust so i'm not going to give them the
benefit of the doubt and assume they
have our best interests
i'm going to assume that cronies within
the us government took the job at
barisma because they found a path
towards making a ton of money for
themselves
not because they actually cared about
the european union and hunter biden took
the job because yeah they needed someone
loyal to the u.s
but they were going to get money for
doing it
you got a bunch of people who work in
government who swap between these big
energy companies and these
military-industrial complex companies
and they make money for themselves
and they operate under the guise of it's
all for the betterment of the country
and when it's not it's for the
betterment of
themselves thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time